a plane plummets out of the sky
a speedrunner inexplicably jumps to a
higher platform what the
what the and an election recount is
triggered
all because of the same invisible
phenomenon that permeates the universe
on may 18 2003 voters in belgium went to
the polls in many regions voting was
done on a computer something the
belgians had been experimenting with for
over a decade but the system had a
backup each voter would insert a
magnetic card into the machine and make
their selection on screen their vote was
saved both to the computer and the
magnetic card which they dropped into a
box for redundancy
late that night as the votes were being
tabulated one of the election officials
detected a problem with the results from
scarbeck a municipality in central
brussels
maria vinde vogel a little-known
candidate with her own party received
more votes than was mathematically
possible
they knew this because the way the
preferential voting system works
so they took out the magnetic cards and
started a recount one by one they fed
each of them through the machines again
and after several hours the recount was
complete the vote totals for every
candidate were exactly the same as
before
except for maria vindivogel in her case
the recounted number of votes was less
than the original by
4096.
so what went wrong how had her original
tally been inflated by over 4 000 votes
computer experts were brought in to run
extensive tests on the software they
combed through the code but could find
no bugs
they got the computer that had made the
initial erroneous tally and tested the
hardware again and again
but they could not replicate the error
everything about the hardware seemed to
be in perfect working order
and this left only one possible
explanation and it is seriously weird
the clue comes from the excess number of
votes vindivogel received 4096.
computers work using binary strings of
zeros and ones each corresponding to a
power of two so somewhere inside the
computer tabulating all the votes was a
string of bits representing the number
of votes maria received it started the
day all zeroes and then as each vote for
her came in it would increment by one
physically this is done by turning on a
transistor for one and turning it off
for zero
what's remarkable about the number 4096
is that it is exactly a power of two two
to the power of twelve
that is the thirteenth bit
so for marie of indivogle to receive an
extra 4096 votes only one thing needed
to happen
the 13th bit had to flip from a zero to
a one
but why would that happen
computers work precisely because bits
don't flip unless we want them to
or do they
looking into the problem belgian
investigators found reports of similar
issues from big computer companies
starting in the 1970s
in 1978 intel reported some strange
errors popping up in their 16 kbit
dynamic random access memory or dram
ones would spontaneously flip to zeros
with no apparent cause
the problem turned out to be the ceramic
packaging the chip was encased in
with the demand for semiconductor
packaging skyrocketing in the 1970s a
new manufacturing plant was constructed
on the green river in colorado
unfortunately this site happened to be
just downstream of an old uranium mill
radioactive atoms made their way into
the river and then into the ceramic
packaging for intel's microchips
scientists investigating the problem
found that even trace amounts of uranium
and thorium in the ceramic were
sufficient to cause problems
in their dram memory was stored as the
presence or absence of electrons in a
semiconductor well the alpha particles
emitted by uranium and thorium were
energetic and ionizing enough to create
electron hole pairs in the silicon
if an alpha particle struck in just the
right place it could create a large
number of free charge carriers causing
electrons to accumulate in the well
flipping a one to a zero
this is known as a single event upset a
type of soft error
the error is soft because the device
hasn't been damaged the bit has changed
but you could erase it and rewrite it
with no problems
investigators exposed the chips to alpha
emitters with different levels of
activity and just as you'd expect they
found the number of bit flips directly
correlated with the number of alpha
particles the chip had been exposed to
the reason this problem was identified
in the 1970s was because chip components
had been miniaturized to the point where
a single alpha particle could produce
enough charge to flip a bit
immediately these findings attracted a
lot of attention before the paper was
published it was widely circulated in
the industry and as a result chip
manufacturers were a lot more careful to
avoid radioactive materials when
producing their microchips and packaging
therefore the bit flip that gave maria
vindivogel 4096 extra votes wasn't
caused by natural radioactivity in the
computer
so where did it come from after henri
beckwerel discovered radioactivity with
uranium in 1896 scientists sought a way
to measure it how radioactive were
different materials and one way to do
this is with a gold leaf electrometer
when it's charged the leaf is repelled
and you can measure the amount of charge
by the angle of the leaf
now if ionizing radiation enters the
chamber it rips electrons off air
molecules creating positive and negative
charges
opposite charges are attracted to the
leaf discharging it over time
the higher the level of ionizing
radiation the faster the device
discharges
in 1910 theodore wolf took his
electrometer to the top of the eiffel
tower
since radioactivity was found in the
soil and rocks of earth he expected that
300 meters up the radiation would be
just a few percent of the ground
radiation
instead he found only a slight decrease
in 1911 austrian physicist victor hess
decided to take this experiment further
literally he loaded electroscopes into
the basket of a hydrogen balloon
in his first two flights he observed the
same thing as wolf up to an altitude of
1100 meters both trips revealed no
fundamental change in radiation compared
to the values observed on the ground
but the next year he conducted seven
balloon flights up to an altitude of
5200 meters
and here he discovered something
remarkable
while there was an initial drop in
radiation for the first several hundred
meters
above one kilometer or so the level
increased with increasing altitude
at his maximum height the level of
radiation was several times greater than
it was on the ground
the radiation appeared to be coming
not from the earth but from the sky
hess scheduled one of his balloon
flights during a solar eclipse and as
the moon passed in front of the sun he
carefully watched his instruments
but the readings were unaffected even
with the sun half covered the level of
radiation was the same
since no influence of the eclipse on the
penetrating radiation was noted we
conclude that even if a part of the
radiation should be of cosmic origin it
hardly emanates from the sun
victor hess had discovered cosmic rays
high energy radiation from space
but what were these rays exactly and
where were they coming from
well today we know they aren't
electromagnetic rays as many suspected
but particles around ninety percent are
protons nine percent or helium nuclei
and one percent are heavier nuclei
some of them are from the sun but they
have comparatively low energy
high-energy cosmic rays moving very
close to the speed of light come from
exploding stars supernovae
in our own galaxy and in others and the
highest energy particles are thought to
come from black holes including the
supermassive black holes at the centers
of galaxies
but it's hard to pin down exactly where
cosmic rays come from because as charged
particles they're deflected by magnetic
fields in space so they can wind their
way through the universe for billions of
years
a cosmic ray detected on october 15 1991
had an energy of 51 joules
that is a single subatomic particle with
the energy of a baseball going a hundred
kilometers per hour
for obvious reasons it was dubbed the
omg particle but primary cosmic rays
like these don't make it down to earth's
surface instead they collide with air
molecules around 25 kilometers above the
ground and create new particles like
pions
these collide and decay into other
particles like neutrons protons muons
electrons positrons and photons
which in turn collide with other air
molecules in one long cascade
so from a single primary cosmic ray
comes a shower of particles streaming
towards the earth
it is one of these particles that
investigators suspect struck a
transistor in a computer in belgium
flipping the 13th bit from a zero to a
one and giving maria vindivogel 4096
extra votes
but how often do things like this happen
in 1911 charles wilson made it possible
to see the cosmic rays all around us
when he perfected his cloud chamber
an enclosure with supersaturated water
or alcohol vapor when a cosmic ray
passes through the chamber it ionizes
the gas causing vapor to condense into
tiny droplets on the ions revealing the
path of the particle
alpha particles helium nuclei leave
short thick tracks while beta particles
electrons leave long skinny trails
in 1932 carl anderson identified a trail
that looked like it was made by an
electron
but in the applied magnetic field it
curved in the wrong direction
implying it had a positive charge
anderson had found the anti-electron or
positron
it was the first confirmed sighting of
antimatter
four years later also using a cloud
chamber he discovered the muon again in
cosmic rays
for his discovery of the positron
anderson was awarded the nobel prize in
physics in 1936
he shared the prize with victor hass the
man who discovered cosmic rays in the
first place
invisible particles that affect our
lives in ways most of us are oblivious
to
this is possibly the rarest thing to
ever happen in a video game
in 2013 user dota teabag was speed
running super mario 64 on the console in
the level tick-tock clock he suddenly up
warps onto a higher platform
what the
invisible wall what please say you got
invisible no that was the craziest thing
i've ever seen though the move shaves
off a few seconds and it seems like a
newly discovered glitch in the game that
could give speedrunners an edge
user panning cook12 put out a one
thousand dollar bounty for anyone who
could replicate the upwarp but so far
after six years
no one has been able to
the best explanation anyone can come up
with is that a cosmic ray caused the
glitch
it's been shown that a single bit flip
in the first byte of mario's height
coordinate could have caused the effect
on the main level the byte was one one
zero zero zero 101 but if you flip the
last one to a zero it changes his
vertical position
and just by chance this new height
coincides with the higher floor
pan and cook 12 wrote a script to
manually flip the bit at the right
moment and was able to achieve the same
up warp
this is a particularly visible bit flip
but the truth is cosmic rays are
triggering bit flips all the time an
upset there transient there can alter
the function of these devices and we
call that a single event functional
interrupt so an entire process can hang
so a blue screen of death that you get
might actually have been a neutron or
whatnot when people see the blue screen
of death could that be caused by a
cosmic ray absolutely
these days there are a number of ways
computer chips are made resilient in the
face of bit flips like error correction
code or ecc memory but you can't totally
prevent bit flips from happening in 1996
ibm estimated that for each 256
megabytes of ram one bit flip occurs per
month the main culprit seems to be
neutrons created in the shower of
particles from cosmic rays
starting in 2009 toyota recalled
millions of vehicles due to the problem
of unintended acceleration we were in
the fast lane driving at about 70 and he
said that the car was continuing to
accelerate
and he couldn't bring it to a stop many
speculated that cosmic ray-induced bit
flips in the electronic control system
were the cause so much so that nasa was
called in to help with the investigation
but it turns out cosmic rays were
probably not the culprit
nasa identified as the main causes
sticky accelerator pedals poorly fitted
floor mats and most commonly drivers
pushing on the accelerator thinking it
was the brake
but cosmic rays have caused crashes of
supercomputers especially at higher
elevations
los alamos national labs located 2200
meters above sea level is constantly
dealing with neutron induced
supercomputer crashes so the software
auto saves frequently and neutron
detectors have been installed throughout
the facility
if you go even higher like climbing up
to cruising altitude in a plane you can
see the radiation from cosmic rays
increasing on a geiger counter to 0.5
microsieverts per hour at 18 000 feet up
to one micro siever per hour at 23 000
feet over two micro sieverts per hour at
33 000 feet and over three micro
sieverts per hour at even higher
altitudes and towards the poles at
cruising altitude this increases the
chance of a single event upset by 10 to
30 times
this isn't critical if it happens in
your laptop but what if it occurs in the
flight computer
on october 7th 2008 an airbus a330 took
off from singapore to perth
just over three hours into the flight
the plane suddenly pitched down diving
200 meters in 20 seconds
inside the plane everyone experienced
negative 0.8 g's of acceleration it
would have felt like the plane had
flipped over
the g-force was enough
even with our three-point harness
to lift us both out of the seat
and push us forward as well
minutes later the plane dropped another
120 meters
119 people on board were injured many
from bumping their heads into the
ceiling so the pilots decided to make an
emergency landing in lirmonth
in the investigation that followed the
fault seemed to occur with the first air
data inertial reference unit or ataroo
for short
this computer supplies critical data
like airspeed angle of attack and
altitude
the way it supplies each of these pieces
of information is in a 32-bit binary
word the first eight bits identify the
type of information and bits 11 to 29
encode the actual data
what seems to have happened is that a
bit flip in the first eight bits meant
altitude information was mislabeled as
angle of attack information
inside the cockpit alarms went on for
overspeed and stall simultaneously
something that should be impossible
but the plane nosed down sharply to
correct what it thought was a stall
throwing passengers and crew into the
ceiling investigators looked into
software bugs software corruption a
hardware fail physical environment
factors and electromagnetic interference
but each of these possibilities was
found to be unlikely based on multiple
sources of evidence
the other potential triggering event was
a single event effect resulting from a
high energy atmospheric particle
striking one of the integrated circuits
within the cpu module
one of the challenges with single event
upsets is that they are soft errors they
don't leave a trace
but interestingly the airbus a330 was
built in 1992 when there were no
specific regulatory or aircraft
manufacturer requirements for airborne
systems to be resilient to single event
effects
with the space shuttle redundancy was
built in from the start
for navigation and control there were
four computers simultaneously running
identical software if one computer had a
soft error the other three would
overrule it
and using this setup they could also
track the frequency of bit flips
on one five-day mission sts-48 there
were 161
separate bit flips
above the atmosphere cosmic rays are so
energetic sometimes you can even see
them
once in a while you have your eyes
closed and you're not asleep yet and
if you wait a little while
you occasionally will see a flash of
light
and we think it is heavy particles or
individual bursts of energy coming from
radiation that are either going through
the eyeball itself or going through the
optic nerve
and
the
the way that your body registers
radiation going through it
is amazingly enough by showing you a
little flash in one of your eyes just to
remind you that you are subject to the
radiation of not only our sun but every
star of the universe that is that is
radiating at you
i picture back to the first astronauts
who must have closed their eyes and seen
that radiation and going
i'm not going to tell anybody about this
because uh no one's told me about i'm
not and i can just imagine the first two
guys that said hey i am sometimes i see
flashes of light do you see flashes of
light and then oh we all see flashes of
light oh okay well that's that's all
right then
for missions to other planets protecting
electronics is critical if a single bit
of information controls a critical
function on your spacecraft let's say
your thrusters and that goes from a one
to a zero from a on off or vice versa
you could lose the mission that's why
the computer on the perseverance rover
that just landed on mars is 20 years old
it's a power pc launched in 2001 with
only 256 megabytes of ram and 2
gigabytes of flash storage
but it is radiation hardened meaning the
design materials circuits and software
are built to withstand 40 times the
radiation of an ordinary computer it's
been used on over a dozen space missions
going back to 2005.
in fact when we first started doing the
power pc testing years ago
the way we did it we just simply stuck
an operating system processor in a beam
line where we we generate these uh
particles on the planet and look for
blue screen to death you can kind of
figure out what's going wrong and try to
undo that so you don't get to the blue
screen of death because a spacecraft
that gets into that mode is basically
unrecoverable
as the voyager 1 spacecraft departed the
solar system one of the ways we could
tell was by an increase in the flux of
cosmic rays it experienced
although on earth the particles
streaming from the sun in the solar wind
are a source of radiation
further out these same particles
maintain a protective bubble the
heliosphere
it helps deflect and slow cosmic rays
from interstellar space protecting the
solar system from ionizing radiation
but the sun has an 11-year activity
cycle so this protection fluctuates the
flux of cosmic rays on earth is much
lower when the sun is active than when
it's dormant
in the history of our planet cosmic rays
may have played an even larger role
flipping bits not in electronics but in
the genetic codes of living organisms
providing some of the variation on which
natural selection acts
maria vindevogel is now a member of the
belgian chamber of representatives
elected by people not a particle but her
story is a reminder of the zillions of
particles winding their way through the
universe for millions or billions of
years
one of which might at any moment
change your life by passing through a
tiny transistor and crap
discovering the origin of cosmic rays or
where 4096 extra votes came from or how
to protect the mars rover from radiation
requires problem solving which is a
perishable skill and the best way to
keep your problem solving skills sharp
is to solve a diverse range of problems
which you can do with the sponsor of
this video brilliant brilliant is a
website and app that teaches you stem
concepts in an interactive way they have
courses on topics from applied computer
science to special relativity two
courses i would recommend if you enjoyed
this video are computer memory and
algorithm fundamentals brilliant have
really upped their interactivity
recently so instead of reading about
algorithms you're taught how to write
algorithms yourself
brilliant engages you in active learning
instead of telling you the right answer
they allow you to figure it out for
yourself with plenty of helpful hints
and guidance along the way and for
viewers of this channel brilliant is
offering 20 off an annual subscription
to the first 200 people to sign up just
go to brilliant.org veritasium i'll put
that link down in the description so i
want to thank brilliant for supporting
veritasium and i want to thank you for
watching